John Wick could have been just another action
movie, but what audiences got was something
else entirely.
John Wick: Chapter 3 - Parabellum hits theaters
May 17, and promises to take viewers even
deeper into the world of assassins and their
various vendettas.
Here's what you should watch before you head
to the theater.
There's a lot of great dialogue in the first
John Wick film, but we all know which one
is the true money line:
"People keep asking if I'm back and I haven't
really had an answer… but now, yeah, I'm
thinking I'm back!"
It's as much a statement about the character
of John Wick as it is a battle cry for Keanu
Reeves the actor.
Reeves had a string of hits in the '90s, including
a little movie you might've heard of called
The Matrix, but then came the sequels.
After their mixed reception, it seemed like
Keanu's star was finally descending.
He continued to work on smaller films and
passion projects, but he didn't truly rise
to prominence again until 2014, when he donned
a suit and dug up a lockbox full of guns and
gold coins in John Wick.
Reeves was back in the spotlight with plenty
of momentum, and will even be returning to
his first iconic role in the long awaited
Bill and Ted Face the Music alongside Alex
Winter.
Yeah, we're thinking he's back.
The first entry in the John Wick franchise
is incredibly straightforward.
For those who haven't seen it — spoiler
alert — a man named John Wick who has recently
lost his wife learns that she had adopted
a puppy for him.
He takes the puppy in and loves it with all
of his heart for a single day.
But after a chance run-in with the dirtbag
son of a mob boss, things go wrong.
That dirtbag son decides he wants John's car,
so he goes and takes it, and in the process,
he kills John's dog.
This is a big mistake,
"May I ask why?"
"Yeah, well.
Cuz he stole John Wick’s car, sir, and…
uh, killed his dog."
Turns out, John is a retired assassin who
was so good at his job that he's essentially
the boogeyman for other hired killers, and
he's mad enough about his dead doggy to get
back in the game and destroy everything in
his path until he gets his revenge.
It's a simple story, but it's told incredibly
well.
Smash cut to John Wick Chapter 2, and we learn
a lot more about the secretive world of the
assassins.
This globetrotting adventure introduces a
high council of assassins and criminal masterminds
— some of whom have unfinished business
with John Wick himself.
Enter Santino D'Antonio, who has a favor to
call in.
"...no."
The job is simple: kill D'Antonio's sister,
Gianna so that he can take her seat at the
table of the high council.
John goes through with it and immediately
becomes entangled in a conspiracy that leads
to D'Antonio placing a massive contract on
John's head to cover his tracks.
The hunt for John Wick escalates to the point
where John is forced to kill someone on the
grounds of the Continental, which is a big
no-no.
By the end of Chapter 2, Wick is on the run
with a one-hour head start to outrun every
assassin in the world, leading to the events
of Chapter 3.
As much as we love the specially-minted gold
coins used by the the killers in John Wick's
world, there's another currency that's just
as important: blood markers.
They're one of the few things that reign in
even the most brutal and relentless of hired
killers, and a blood marker is only earned
when another assassin does someone an immense
favor.
They can then claim that marker at any time
to call in any favor in return.
It cannot be refused — it's taken as seriously
as spilling blood within the halls of the
Continental.
"Rules."
"Exactly: rules."
The reason John had to take the job to kill
a member of the High Table was a marker held
by Santino D'Antonio — one that he earned
by helping John get out of the assassin's
life, and go live his fairy tale existence
with his wife in peace before the events of
the first film.
By the end of Chapter 2, as John Wick goes
to take his head start in escaping with an
open contract for $14 million on his head,
Winston gives him a blood marker which may
act as his only lifeline now that he's been
made excommunicado from the league of assassins.
In the first two John Wick films, we've already
seen a seen an incredible roster of over-the-top
characters populating the shadowy, stylish
underworld where anyone could be an assassin
just waiting for the right moment to strike.
That doesn't seem likely to change as we get
into Chapter 3, with both returning characters
and some brand-new faces.
Ian McShane will be back as Winston, the manager
of the Continental, and Keanu's Matrix co-star,
Laurence Fishburne, will be returning as the
mysterious Bowery King, a seemingly homeless
man with a deep knowledge of the world of
Assassins and a love of pigeons.
"Seven million dollars?
Damn!
It’s Christmas.
We're going to Applebee's after this!"
Here's hoping that the minds behind the John
Wick franchise can find a place for Carrie-Anne
Moss, if she's interested, completing the
— ahem — Trinity.
Seeing the three stars of The Matrix reunited
on screen, even for a short time, would be
pretty awesome.
As for the new characters, Parabellum has
upped the ante with an impressive roster of
stars.
Halle Berry will appear as Sofia, a former
accomplice of John's who wields two pistols
and two dogs, while Anjelica Huston joins
up as the severe, calculating Director.
Mark Dacascos will play the nefarious Zero,
while comedy favorite Jason Mantzoukas will
play the oddly-named and undoubtedly weird
Tick Tock Man.
Keanu Reeves has been a lifelong fan and practitioner
of martial arts, but few roles have been as
demanding of him as John Wick.
Reeves went all in a nd spent three months
at a "John Wick boot camp" to work on firearms
training, fight choreography, and driving
like a maniac.
Some of the training involved Reeves working
on his drawing, holstering, and even search-and-seizure
techniques.
This helped him and the stunt team come up
with a unique style of movement and gunplay.
No one moves quite like John Wick.
Reeves is also heavily involved in the stunts.
It'll be a wild ride to see how the stunt
team — and stuntmen-turned-filmmakers Chad
Stahelski and David Leitch — up the ante
for Chapter 3 as John Wick's world only continues
to get wilder and more dangerous.
One of the best things about the secretive
world of assassins and gigantic Super Mario
gold coins that's presented in the John Wick
movies is that there's just enough to let
us know that there's plenty we haven't seen.
Those looking for a slightly expanded version
of that world, however, may have something
to look forward to.
There is currently a spin-off television show
in the works at Starz.
Called The Continental, it will showcase a
new kind of adventure in the world of John
Wick, focusing on a brand new character who's
pulled into the world as the story unfolds.
Starz has its eyes on making a television
show that captures the slick ferocity of the
John Wick films and has tapped the original
co-directors and producers Chad Stahelski
and David Leitch, as well as original writer
Derek Kolstad — and, of course, executive
producer Keanu Reeves.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
obsessions are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.